rocket fire in der azur province syria
on monday
a military base used by american troops
came under attack
just a day after the u.s military bombed
three militia outposts
along the syrian iraqi border u.s
president joe biden was
unapologetic i directed last night's
airstrikes
targeting sites used by the
iranian-backed
militia group responsible for recent
attacks on
u.s personnel in iraq and i have that
authority under article two
and even those up in the hill who are
reluctant to
acknowledge that have acknowledged
that's the case
the popular mobilization forces or pmf
say the u.s strikes killed at least four
of their men
the fighters who are backed by iran say
they will retaliate
tehran officials quickly condemned the
attacks
u.s still continues the wrong path in
the region what we see today is not only
the sanctions but also following the
wrong policies in previous
administrations
in regard with actions they carry out in
the region
u.s troops have been in eastern syria
for the past
several years helping local fighters put
down the isil regime
they've also been deployed in iraq part
of a train and support mission
but baghdad says washington did not give
advance warning before sunday's bombings
at the alkheim border crossing
these latest clashes come at a sensitive
moment both countries are still trying
to work out a return to the iran nuclear
deal
one u.s foreign policy expert says the
biden administration
has to be very careful in how it
proceeds
in a sense it is trying to
to prevent this from from reaching a
point where it affects for example
you know ongoing negotiations in vienna
yeah we'll wait and see whether
this is the beginning of an escalation
or just a
a one-off you know the kind of periodic
back and forth that we
have seen many times between iranian
proxy forces and u.s forces
a test of the biden administration's
promise to rely on diplomacy
until it has no other choice rosalind
jordan al jazeera washington